Daily Show founded by Craig kilor and
many of you are not old enough to
remember that then becomes very popular
at least among uh DC journalists and you
know makes a big splash under John
Stewart then it's taken over by Trevor
Noah who has never said a funny thing
ever once in his life and they let him
keep that show for a while eventually he
leaves now it's just been a cycle of
Fillin hosts this guy is Charlemagne the
God is is his uh stage name and he's a
radio host we've played clips of him
before he's he's pretty funny he's
obviously a big
lib here is Charlemagne the God's take
on President Biden so Donald Trump is
currently running on a platform of
dictatorship and the only man standing
in his way is President Joe Biden seeing
here looking at his own approval
ratings I know he thinks he's got this
in the bag but the polls say otherwise I
want Biden stepping in to beat Trump the
way I want him stepping in to defend me
at a bar
fight I appreciate you Karen but I don't
like our chances
the point is we don't need Biden to beat
Donald Trump just like we didn't need
RBG to stay on the court okay maybe if
RBG had retired during the Obama years
we'd still have Ro v Wade maybe but
people said no she needs to be here to
protect Ro and now look both of them are
gone it's true they're both
gone see the facts are Biden's not
getting any younger he's not going to
get any more popular and he's not
getting a new running mate so please Mr
President give America The Ultimate
Christmas gift and step
aside you know this is not the funniest
monologue I've ever seen But compared to
years of Trevor
Noah this guy is nor McDonald Bob Hope
and Rodney Dangerfield all rolled up
into one you know this guy is really
really much funnier than Trevor Noah and
his point is much
better yeah Joe Biden is a major
liability for the Democrats I agree
Donald Trump could conceivably beat Joe
Biden if the libs don't rig it I totally
agree maybe even if the libs do rig it
is just Biden's approval ratings are so
low and Trump seems to be doing pretty
well
head-to-head all that said though I bet
that Biden is still the nominee I'm not
sure about that I know there are a lot
of Democrats and Republicans who are
saying no he's at the last minute he's
going to step aside and nah he's not he
can't run again he's too old he's too
scile it's not going to happen
I'm not betting the farm but I would bet
a small amount of money Joe Biden will
be the Democrat nominee for president
barring some you know major health
incident I just don't think this guy is
going to step aside voluntarily I think
Joe Biden has wanted to be the president
since he was in the womb I think it
would be embarrassing to leave after one
term it would be a sign of failure and I
don't think he wants to do it and he
doesn't like Kamala Harris he hates her
kamla Harris launched her campaign
calling Joe Biden a racist Joe Biden has
no love for KLA Harris he is not going
to do it for Pete Budaj jedge give me a
break the the silly mayor of South Bend
uhuh you know you don't get to go on
maternity leave when you're the
president of the United States he's not
doing that he's not maybe Gavin Newsome
he's the most in the Biden mold but I
don't think Biden cares about anybody
really I think Biden cares about Biden
right now text nolles to 200 300 for
most home owners window replacement is
not something they want to do but rather
something they have to do have you put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive then I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free quote
from Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature servic is committed
to giving you the best customer
experience possible supported by the
best people in the industry right now
Renewal by Anderson is offering a free
inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for $0 down zero payments
and zero interest for one year text
nolles kwes to 200 300 for your free
consultation and save $375 off every
window and $750 off every door these
savings will not last long so be sure to
check it out text nolles kwes to 200 300
I have gotten unsolicited emails there
was a carpenter who wrote to me and said
Michael I heard you do a read for
Renewal by Anderson whenever I work on a
home with Windows by Renewal by Anderson
it's just superior quality text nolles
to 200 300 texting privacy policy and
terms and conditions posted to text
plan. us texting enrolls for recurring
automated text marketing messages
messaging datas May apply reply stop to
out go to window appointment now.com for
full offer details right now go to
stpaul center.com I recently had my
friend Dr Scott Han on the show he is
the founder of the St Paul Center which
is one of the fastest growing Catholic
organizations in the world the St Paul
Center's mission is to give you the
tools you need to know to love scripture
better to become more confident in your
faith and most importantly to grow
closer to Christ himself in order to
achieve this the St Paul Center founded
a new digital learning platform called
EMAs Academy EMAs Academy features every
20 video courses book studies and
original series giving you the ability
to learn from worldclass theologians
such as Dr Scott Han and Dr John Burma
as if you were right there with them in
the classroom I absolutely love their
video studies I love everything that
they put out their 12 session study by
doct Han is incredible he traces the
meaning of Holiness from its origins in
scripture to its appearance in our own
lives today this study will help you
experience the transformative power of
God's holiness start learning more about
church history how to interpret the
Bible the basics of Christian prayer and
more good to stpaul
center.com and you can begin exploring
EMAs Academy memberships are only 25
bucks per month but you can sign up
today for a two-e free trial imagine
what could be possible if we were all to
fortify ourselves with a deeper
understanding of scripture and Faith do
not miss this opportunity to sign up
today to begin your journey with Emmas
Academy and further more even from the
perspective of the democratic
party it just looks back bad to lose
your nominee e even if Biden is polling
in in pretty bad numbers right
now it's a sign of weakness this is why
you always hear this uh when when a
president is running for re-election
they say will he change his running mate
oh that running mate's not that popular
comma Harris is first of all presidents
often benefit if they have a slightly
weak running mate because it's an
argument against impeachment or
assassination but
two if you change things up you are
admitting that you have failed and right
now that Democrats are still straight
face saying Biden he's achieved so much
so much oh things have never been better
a gallon of milk costs $300 now but
things have never we've got World War
III breaking out in Eastern Europe and
in the Middle East but no things are
just thank goodness it's not like it was
under Trump when the economy great was
great and we had World Peace yeah no
thank goodness now everything's broken
but they're straight facing it and if
they're going to straight face it then
they got to keep the nominee to lose the
nominee is to admit that the guy failed
that he was too too old he was too weak
too incompetent never underestimate
Joe's ability to F things up to quote
the former Democrat president so my
money a modest amount of money he's stle
the nominee now speaking of the
presidential nominees a poll has just
come out from three groups you know they
always say it's like the
ABC Harvard poll or whatever well this
is the 538 Washington Post ipsos poll so
goodness gracious that's three groups
and they say that Ronda santis won the
fourth Republican debate and I basically
agree with that he won in the sense that
he was the most steady the most
presidential sure okay I I think that
the debate was the best debate by far I
think Megan Kelly by far was the best
moderator we've seen at any of these
debates really at any debate in recent
years but so what so what Ronda santis
won the debate cool how are the poll
numbers moving uh not at
all why be sometimes winning a debate
helps the problem is these debates were
not actually presidential debates
because the guy who is leading the pack
by 40 or 50 points even didn't show up
so it was a fun little exercise it was a
simulacrum of a presidential debate it
was a distant faint echo of a pres but
it even if you hate Trump and you like
DeSantis or V or Haley or chrisy if
you're the one guy out there me who just
loves the croissance and is waiting for
the croissant to just totally to
then even still I think you have to
admit it just doesn't matter that and a
buck 50 will get you a cup of coffee man
that was a great clip huh huh well now
wait wait you got to ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time